petton les nuls bonsoir martin veyron
bonsoir marque voler une bon soir quand
j'ai lu vos vies j'ai vu qu'ils étaient
tous les trois pieds noirs non les
garçons gagnent les garçons pieds noirs
qui est auvergnate où l'on fasse si on
veut et pourquoi vous avez perdu
l'accent parce qu'il a fait nous un
petit plan comme ça là bas et on n'est
pas typé du tout pour donner un peu dur
à toi un peu quand même un petit peu
mieux ce oui oui on a donné un nom
pareil y'a pas toi comment ça se passe
les miraculés superstar en accédant à la
limite se retrouve alors comment ça se
passe avec lescure innocent sur certains
trucs c'est moi on m'a dit là l'histoire
du chien l'attend wendel oui alors c'est
qu'elle sait quoi c'était quoi l'on me
raccompagne chanter on avait envie pour
démarrer les émissions de battre faire
un petit clin d'oeil si j'ose dire aux
otages oui bon on était allé tourner un
jour dans une spa
on l'avait vu des chiens comme sa sortie
des vacances tous derrière des barreaux
et tout et on s'est dit ah les pauvres
sont emprisonnés eux aussi voilà j'en
avais envie de faire de 200 cinquième
jour de détention sur peugeot et on
était vachement fier de cette idée et un
soir au restaurant avec lescure
effectivement vont lui en parle
au départ ils étaient un peu
enthousiaste en disant ouais c'est vrai
que c'est drôle et puis le lendemain
après une nuit de réflexion qui nous a
convoqués en a parlé tous ensemble ça
pète une censure usa vous pensez
vraiment que c'est drôle au clown pour
la première c'était la première moyens
ou si c'est pour cette moyen de faire
des trucs pas mal à ce qu'on vient de
voir sa part dans le lieu des
discussions paintsil et basf alors
qu'est ce qui s'est passé là c'est la
société basf qui est bon et einstein ce
fut un jeu presque celle initiale j'ai
connu bien des regards très jolies
tresses ou qui eux ont vu les photos
dans le monde le président actuel aussi
donc avec la tronche de kurt valdan le
truc c'était donc qui pleurait sur
deschamps résisté bss l'émotion intacte
elles ont vu cette image est là la pub
deux autres
et donc ils ont bloqué c'est pourquoi
avec respect pourquoi la guerre il était
séparé si on veut pas dire avoir une
protection n'est jamais d'accord ils
sont quand même assez mouillé dans l'est
dans les larmes et ils ont déjà beaucoup
or le 7 d'or il vous augmentez chez
canal+ parce qu'ils sont comme tout chez
canal+ dont ils nous ont conté avant que
deux avant cet échange est sauvé il
savait train se renseigner et vous avez
des propositions de bouygues de comptes
annuels et alors comment s'est passé a
raconté comme des propositions nous a
demandé si on voulait aller faire une
licence en ligne et/ou break
on est bien à canal quoi on a deux
interlocuteurs valables dans la des gens
simplement se sont nettement
est-ce que ce qui passe à l'heure
actuelle sur notre chaise au canada
pourrait passer à une heure de grande
écoute sur la une c'est un acteur de 45
changer ça change kg dans le sens de la
roue de la fortune que dans le champ au
sens de tennie glande il faut bien le
dire c'est pas de marseille a décru
remarquer jean n'a remarqué c'est pas
très drôle mais c'est bien bon alors on
va tous les prendre un par an là puisque
vous faites un journal télévisé
nullement gildas je vous demanderai pas
ce que vous en pensez parce que
j'imagine que c'est votre pote gildas
mahé alors poivre d'arvor
alors là je le paie lui à bord à lui
c'est le pire
je l'avais personnes ouais j'suis à lui
c'est le pire il fait à bord alors
pourquoi ces changements épidermique
mais pourquoi était déjà bouton aborde
et oui lui alors qu'il est pourquoi il
est pas plus mal canal moins chaud
niveau après bonzi j'aime bien c'est
rigolo un petit plus que ce même pas qui
s'est faufilé gens qui n'ont rien gens
sont gentils accueillants gentil
toujours complet cuba date tue pas sur
mon prix madère
guillaume durand avec jérôme dupont très
bien et c'était ça la 5e dimanche à 16h
pour ça c'est bien bon d'accord
jean claude bourret c'est bien il a un
nom prédestiné les bons ballons tu as
bien vite arrivé avec ses côtés
jean-pierre furnon ex-aequo âgées pas
dans ces gens là bruno masure
j'aime bien avec toulouse sont donc tout
ce que vous dites que vous avez bien
c'est que vous feriez bien le jt n avait
que joseph kony sans faute d'accord
henri sannier jeunesse et à la vie en
plein de séries télé bretagne et qu'on
n'a jamais vous ne s'est jamais vu en
gîte et ouais concurrents patrick
sébastien c'est bien moi je trouve que
c'est d'action la démolir juste moi ça
je veux dire parce que son émission il
se déclare non il se décarcasse mais ne
faut pas déconner faut regarder ce qui
fait comme un gibier sur des idées qu'on
aime qu'on n'aime pas bon ce qu'on lui
reproche un peu c'est d'être un peu trop
gentil avec tout le monde c'est vrai
qu'il aime trop tout le monde mais quand
même ya tout le temps des valois qui
laisse pas une femme moi de pionnier
c'est alors alors collaro ou bien parce
que vous êtes kitai à d'autres
programmes de l'a5
alors non on n'est pas au programme de
nuages roucas caché pas son nom mais
aucun ne s'est pas fait moins bien que
les nullités qui s'est passé la csn fait
pas rire bon ben ça fait pas grand monde
du cinéma
enfin les inconnues sont comme vous sont
quatre bien sûr savoir que jamais vu sur
scène - après leur faux pas lors les
imitateurs d'alors andré lamy il imite
les lui renvoie limites que les morts
c'est un mec il pourrait se mettre
mais qui est capable d'imiter connu tout
ça il se met sur un drap avec quatre
bougies autour sur un drap noir et soit
parfait alors eric blanc qui sait ça ces
deux manches également reconnu avoir eu
très nettement le bahreïn c'est bien
c'est alors il est formé à la télévision
ça arrive pas souvent quand on fait du
skate
quand on prend comme ça l'équipe où il
est bien difficile mais avant vidéo
il fait bien mitterrand et que vient
giscard il fait bien mais les demandes
est bien c'est qu'on arrive à oublier
dans ses imitations qu'il est noir il
est noir c'est le noir qui aime les gens
et de reconstruire ses journaux alors
est ce que vous connaissez martin veyron
intérêt à dire oui oui maman l'accord
l'amour propre ne le reste jamais très
longtemps à la fin
alors martin panou ton livre - les
livres ton dernier livre bien il sort
quelques années après l'amour propre
ouais et après ils sont un petit peu
énervé russe dans l'amour propre écran
de salon comme sales et mal élevé il se
mariera jamais faite pour les hommes qui
prévient pour élever l'enfant et ça dit
quoi par exemple du moins le truc le
plus drôle du livre bombe a rendu tout
d'abord c'est très sérieux
c'est pour élever les chiens thales a eu
le plaisir maintenant tu paies et autant
que ce soit bien fait tara combien le
chien mais pouvait tenir mais vous devez
pas dit oui il ya eu une petite fille en
exergue
alors c'est une fois ce qui dit les
enfants c'est comme l'épée on ne
supporte que les ciaccio c'est bien
c'est pas génial et c'est d'elizabeth
chai qui vise à battre ferrer c'est pas
une copine à l'égard des pêcheurs c'est
une
c'est une philosophe c'est ma tante en
plus avant mais mais la raison en marque
veut lui une ces climats possibles soit
je ne connais pas un as de 10 à 17
heures au visage oui on trouve que canal
ouais qu'est ce qu'il raconte moi c'est
beau qu'est ce qu'il raconte en bd ouais
on me dise des histoires assez assez
personnelle assez monde et demande
intérieure philosophique c'est un peu à
part c'est il ya il ya trois ans il ya
le directeur artistique de vanille tic
magazine italien au bode qui s'est dit
tiens on fait toujours faire la mode
pour les photographes pourquoi on ne
demanderait pas à le dessinateur de bd
parce que mon la bd monte bien et il a
donc demandé à mattotti al hodoud de
jantes d'illustrer le travail des
designers et ça a très bien marché
les stylistes était content parce qu'on
vend dédié leur modèle la revue du coup
les marchés et le résultat de ce niveau
là c'est ça s'il un truc assez mattotti
pour vanity voie d'accord c'est tout ce
qu'il a fait pour illustrer la valeur
très bien vous avez quelque chose à
ajouter les enfants nancy des billets
sur l'a5 alors à fond alors si on a ça
qu'on m'a jamais rien interdit justement
ce ce extraordinaire
d'ailleurs on me laisse faire tout ce
que je veux et si c'est pas terrible ce
n'est pas de leur faute et les trucs un
peu sa liste arrive donc il ya pas de
faim il faudrait ce que ma fille je
dirais qu'elle plonge tout à chaque
émission